He's still alive.
You wanna talk about it?
Every night I have the same nightmare.
That day…
that was hell.
I remember…
people screaming.
What's going on?
They get bitten and then they turn.
And you watch it spread...
and spread.
It's terrifying.
Leon?
It's gotta be another outbreak.
I gotta go.
Don't do anything stupid.
Raccoon City was the beginning.
We can't let what happen stay buried.
If we went public with this…
we could expose a conspiracy.
I can't get anyone to go on record
about the outbreak.
I'm sorry, I don't know what to tell you.
We need to show the world
that we are a strong nation.
Capable of protecting the interests
of the free world.
We must be the source of hope
to those who seek freedom.
We cannot allow anyone
to interfere with peace and prosperity.
What are you here for?
That's classified.
Do you know where the root
of terror comes from?
It starts with fear.
I will show you fear.